no I was going to ask you
um what made you stop drinking
um [__] just knowing this wrong was
about to go on and I was going out all
the time
and you know what I'm saying so like I
look at it like I have to sacrifice I
can't do everything you know I'm saying
it's hard to say no too because you're
doing clubs yeah you know what I'm
saying because I have to preserve myself
I know the run I'm not trying to go and
I know like to go so like I just like
you know what I'm gonna cut this out I
got my other little
little tricks that I do but like the
drinking part I could have no more no
more alcohol and then also it's like
obviously I lost a lot of calories it's
like unneeded bruh I feel like [__] the
next day and you're about to go on the
road you want to be a [__] straight
chiseled up bro you know for the road
I'm definitely about to get right but I
just like I feel like [__] the next day
it's crazy I don't know some people can
go crazy like that and be like [__] I'm
we up at nine o'clock tell me about your
relationship with psychedelics
man I have a long-standing relationship
with plant medicine I don't like to
disrespecting my calling them
psychedelics okay because some people
take that wrong I call it plant medicine
plant medicine um I just respect I feel
like there's so many different healing
um
properties in plant medicine are you
talking about shrooms you talk about
peyote I uh DMC all that I definitely
think it's not something you take every
day you know what I'm saying shrooms you
can but sometimes yeah you can micro
dose every day right be productive the
other ones is like yeah you're not going
to do DMT every day if you want to sit
with yourself and you want to kind of
see yourself in in super present moment
outside of time and space like for me I
think taking plant medicine
reminds you where you who you are beyond
the physical right and and it's there it
could also be therapy it's it's deep
therapy therapy with yourself that
nobody else can help you with you just
have to be ready to face yourself
um honestly speaking I wish that my
mother would have taken
Ayahuasca or some of these plant
medicine it would help with her
addiction I'm sure one thousand percent
I feel the same way about people think
if I would have known that I would have
that's something I definitely would have
if there's people in my life who like I
was growing up with like my family
members and I'm like damn like if I had
a you know I got family members I've
overdosed yeah and been through all that
[__] too so it's like damn like I just
think right now even if you don't take
plant medicine right now is the time to
just expand your horizons as a being you
know we are faced we're in a spiritual
war right now so it's time to like
really tap in with yourself on a whole
other level because life ain't gonna get
easier if you don't start to understand
who you are well they just uh
decriminalized it in Oakland San
Francisco
obviously Oregon Washington Canada but I
think the whole state of California is
coming soon
Therapeutics the therapeutic purposes
because people who have PTSD have been
in the military yep
um shout out to all the veterans man
they could really get one of my homes is
better there's even like MDMA therapy
you know so there's definitely a lot
like I have a friend of mine who was
probably the biggest degenerate I top
five I've ever met in my life
um and this dude did he went to Malibu
and he did two days of Ayahuasca wow and
it was like it was almost like a he said
it was like 30 years of therapy yeah man
wrapped up in a two days because so what
happens is that we hold so much trauma
in our in our tissue and our bones and
where because we're vibrational beings
these things sit there and they don't
leave until we work them out and they're
suppressed you don't even you might not
even know they're there even though
they're there yeah right and so
um when you do these plant medicines
what happens is it goes in and literally
vibrationally breaks things up and opens
you up opens your pineal gland opens you
up so you can see and feel everything
that's why some people they go they have
trips that are like not as good because
they're purging all of this [__] yeah
right that they've been holding on for
years and years and even past life
traumas and all this type of [__] so
it's really it's not a joke you know
what I'm saying it's not it's not people
think it's like a party thing and it's
like no this is like some real medicine
for real like it's a medicine for real
exactly exactly like I think of like uh
I just expecting all [__] going on and
all these people overdose I'm like man
if they would just legalize some of this
[__] it would like change a lot of
people's lives because I think biggest
thing with addiction is like the
withdrawals getting people off [__]
getting people like disconnected from
right people want to attending people
want want that that numbness some people
want the numbness some people just wanna
do it for Creative purposes some people
are addicts to it some people I just
think people like to sometimes have some
type of escape and you can micro dose
before you work out
it gives you a little I never did that
before I got homies who are jacked and
they will do a micro doses their
pre-workout which is yeah I'm like hey
that's it good for you I'm not doing
that but yeah
um how are you feeling about all the new
alien news that's been coming out
alien did you see that well the guy I
mean it's been aliens I mean we it's
just old news to me in my opinion I mean
I agree too oh [__] listen I'm like
I'm inside of it no but I know I feel
like I'm watching a cartoon
I feel like they're preparing us for
something a little bit though but the
Hebrew word for Elion is is is a being
of light is is it even involved being
you know so it's like we are aliens like
you know what I'm saying it's like if
you if you understand what's happening
if you really study I mean all of this
and make people just want to study
everything study everything you can so
that you'll see that this movie that
they're trying to play for you is not
real and this [__] is all [__] and
it's just I don't know it's just so
obvious we are the aliens why are we
here what do you think is your calling
Mario outside of music I'm talking 20 30
years from now if if we could remember
you I'm not saying I don't believe in
other entities that have been here and
are here and other off Planet but I
don't believe how they're trying to
depict they actually downgrading what's
actually happening what's you know what
I'm saying they're giving us the diet
version yeah it's like yeah they're
giving us the sugar for you want to tap
into off-planet energies you can do that
yourself you don't need the government
to do it just get to my washers have you
done DMT yes yeah was it fun
it's it's
um 15 minutes right maybe they're like
eight miles less than eight to ten
minutes I was having sex while I was
doing it I ain't gonna lie I was like
fully awake like I'm I'm bro I
yes what's that like
super like you're you don't really feel
the physical act of it but because it's
your your body is not really you don't
feel your body right you feel everything
you lit everything is just
there's no separation wow from what I
experienced and um yeah but I was still
very much so in my body and very much so
in my light body so it's just like yeah
I've I've yes it was interesting I've
yet to do DMT I'm a little I haven't
done it in a while I'm a little
intimidated because uh I have a friend
who does it and he'll do it once or
twice a year and he freebases it so he
does it like where he does it I've been
there when he did it and I got sketched
I was like I think that when you take
plant medicine
depending on where you are spiritually
where you are awareness-wise and
consciously is going to affect you
different every time yeah so he like was
gone for like about 15 minutes and came
back and was like
what he remembered because he's like
there's just too much [__] coming in for
me to like really remember everything
but she was like it felt like I was gone
for like six months since it was like
going to work and living a life like in
15 minutes I was like this is crazy like
I don't want to be somewhere for six
months yeah I mean anytime now that I do
anything I always set intentions now but
I do I think intention is important yeah
because if even if you're going if
you're doing if you're doing psilocybin
your intention is important because you
could be if you're at the club and
you're drinking and you're like let's do
some shrooms while I'm drinking whiskey
shots and together shots every time it's
chemistry every time you're doing
different things you're adding a
different vibrational uh response to it
yeah you're changing the state of it by
mixing it with something else so you're
gonna have a different reaction it's
just like when you walk in certain rooms
your energy can shift the room based
upon your because everybody has your
magnetic field 360 Degrees around them
and whatever's in that field it could be
the person he was with last night it
could be your it's so much [__] going on
you gotta be selective for you let
around here man yeah or or maybe you
want that energy and you want to use
this you just I just think you just have
to be aware whatever you're calling
about whatever you want to happen good
or bad whatever is your world do do as
you will but you know just know